good afternoon welcome my name is
Natalie McKee and I am a senior here at
Hillsdale College studying English and
journalism and I have the honor this
afternoon of introducing mister dr.
grant wacker he is the Gilbert T row
professor emeritus at Christian of
Christian history at Duke Divinity
School and earned his PhD from Harvard
University a trustee of the fuller
thought Theological Seminary he
previously taught in the Department of
Religious Studies at the University of
North Carolina at Chapel Hill he is past
president of the Society for Pentecostal
studies of the American of the American
Society of church history and he is a
former senior editor of the journal
Church history studies in Christianity
and culture he is the author and
co-editor of several books including
heaven below early Pentecostals and
American culture religion in the
nineteenth century America and America's
pastor Billy Graham and the shaping of a
nation please join me in welcoming him
tonight
Thank You Natalie
it was a gracious invitation it is a
great honor to be here today
I've never been to Hillsdale for that
matter never been in Central Michigan
and so I've heard a great deal about
Hillsdale over the years and so finally
I have a chance to come and thank you to
Matt for inviting me and not the least
of the pleasures of coming is that two
very dear friends I've known seems like
forever Darrell and Ann Hart are here as
well Darrell is a historian teaches us
history and it's very very nice to see
both Darrell and and here well when I
when I saw the lineup of speakers I have
to say I was intimidated and so I told
my wife about this lineup of speakers
and I told her how intimidated I was and
she said look don't try to be
intellectual don't try to be profound
don't try to be funny
just be yourself
so that's where we are I'm gonna just
just try try to be myself this afternoon
okay now I want to start with a couple
of preliminary comments I tell my
graduate students at Duke never start
with the preliminary comment but none of
my graduate students is here so I'm
gonna go ahead and do it okay the first
one is a minor one about scope in the
today I will talk about Billy Graham but
in the context of American life and
culture he's very much an international
figure and I think in the long run we
might find that Graham's ministry
overseas was even more important than
what he did in the United States but
working on Graham in the United States
was work enough for one day one lifetime
for me and so that is my focus though I
would welcome any questions about the
overseas part the second is is it
several of you have asked me about him
and the person who gave me a ride from
the airport a couple of days ago asked
me if he was still alive and the answer
is very much yes he is approaching 98
years old he lives in his house that he
has been in for something like 70 years
it's on a mountaintop near Asheville
North Carolina a relatively modest house
actually and what's most surprising to
me is that he lives alone now he does
have nurses around the clock and 8-hour
shifts but other than that he's alone
and so I mean it's just astonishing to
me this man who has been in intense
interaction with hundreds thousands
hundreds of thousands of people
throughout his life and now in the end
of his life he he chooses this and I
think he spends a lot of time just
looking at the mountains in relatively
good health for
a man who's approaching 98 my assigned
topic today is Billy Graham the
relationship of life and times now this
is a capacious topic and it would take
hours if not days to fully cover it so
this afternoon I want to focus on a more
manageable but equally important
question and that question is how graham
shaped is x it's almost needless to say
that the x shaped him too but i wish to
argue that through sheer force of mind
will and personality graham itched deep
lines in the sands of his age now let me
first say a few words about Graham
stature on the American religious
landscape in the long second half of the
20th century though he's familiar to
students of American religion and
probably to most people in this room as
well
in 2007 Gallup poll revealed that nearly
one-third of Americans under the age of
30 had absolutely no idea who he was or
yes it's worth remembering what one Wall
Street Journal reviewer recently said
about Graham's place in post-world War
two America he said it's easy to forget
what a big deal he was in his time for
more than five decades Graham ranked as
one of the most influential voices in
the Christian world born on a farm near
Charlotte North Carolina
Graham spent the early years of his
ministry mainly as an itinerant speaker
for youth for christ in the midwest but
highly publicized crusades in los
angeles in 1949 and then in new york in
1957 hurled him into the national and
international spotlights
and he held that iconic position for the
rest of the century and beyond Graham's
achievements piled up like snowdrifts
just a few most notably nearly 215
million people around the world heard
him preach in person probably more than
any other person in history additional
hundreds of millions heard him by way of
electronic media between 1959 excuse me
between 1955 and last year he scored a
spot on gallops list of 10 most admired
men in the world 59 times nearly twice
the figure of his closest rival Ronald
Reagan in that regard
Graham was less a preacher than a
Protestant Saint with help from
journalism giants William Randolph
Hearst and Henry R lose Graham
masterfully adopted his old-fashioned
gospel to new media besides more than 30
books that either authored or authorised
they introduced the our decision weekly
national radio program in 1950 the hour
of decision quarterly network television
program in 1951 worldwide pictures a
feature-length film division in 1951 my
answer a daily syndicated advice column
in 1952 with the potential readership of
20 million people a day he introduced
Christianity today a serious theological
fortnightly in 1956 in decision magazine
a popular magazine in 1960 at one point
decision reached 6 million all of the
other radio broadcasts in television
worldwide pictures they too reached
millions whatever else Graham was he was
a man of bold ambitions his
international Crusades and evangelism
conferences especially Lausanne in 1974
helped make his name a household word
not only in the United States but in
many other parts of the world
hmm Graham personally knew 12 presidents
of the United States
he claimed 10 of them as friends Lyndon
Johnson Richard Nixon Ronald Reagan and
the younger Bush excuse me the older
Bush and their first ladies were all
close friends for more than five decades
Graham enjoyed extraordinary if not
unique access to the pinnacle a
political and cultural power many viewed
Graham unfavorably but their attacks
also served as a mark of status his
susceptibility to the glamour of
celebrities the clout to the ultra-rich
and the influence of high-ranking
politicians troubled his friends and
energized his foes his odious remarks
about Jews in the media uttered in
private in Nixon's Oval Office in 1972
but revealed in 2002 tarnished his
record his repeated apologies lightened
but never eased the stain yet most
disturbing for all but the most ardent
followers was Graham's political posture
in the 1960s in the early 70s his
support for the Vietnam War and his jut
jaw defense of Nixon during wall during
Watergate lingered long after most
Americans had given up on both causes
many called him the White House chaplain
some observers harsh attitudes toward
Graham did soften over time Martin
Marty's pilgrimage represented many
others in 1988 on the occasion of
Graham's 70th birthday this mainline
Lutheran clergyman and one of the most
renowned historians in the world
admitted that in times past he had
grumbled in print about Graham's
approach but now in 1988 Marty judged
this is wonderful quotation
that left-and-right liberal or
conservative mean less than mean and non
mean and gram to our great fortune has
been of the non mean variety Marti kept
moving in a conference just a couple of
years ago just down the street at
Wheaton College the conference was
devoted analyzing Graham's legacy and
Marty said that the Mount Rushmore of
American religious history clearly
included four figures Jonathan Edwards
Martin Luther King and Billy Graham then
Marty winked and he said I haven't
decided on the fourth one yet if you all
know Marty you know how a characteristic
that is but this is a remarkable change
letters from ordinary people to Gram
reveal his status to I'll say more about
them later but here the point to notice
is the sheer magnitude of the letters
running to millions posted during the
six decades he strode the public stage
children's letters are significant in
their own way I love them one children's
letter posted one child's letter posted
in 1971 probably if I'm a first or
second grader I assume from the
handwriting letters spoke for a lot
after a free book young author signed
off tell mister Jesus hi now think about
that but that says about Graham's
interaction with popular culture the
envelopes he carried the letters from
adults now exhibited in the Billy Graham
library showcase are very revealing to
some bore only a sketchy address some
had wildly inaccurate addresses and some
had no addresses at all one that I saw
simply had a picture of Billy Graham
taped on the front but they all made it
they got to his headquarters one that I
especially liked included a full and
accurate address but down in the lower
left-hand corner
the rider had scrawled in case of
rapture never mind
now these stories tell us a great deal
about the depth and breadth of Graham's
interaction with popular culture I'm
going to offer one additional anecdote
that goes far to document Graham's
influence in this case beyond
evangelical circles it comes from a very
unlikely source Bob Dylan who was
interviewed in the AARP magazine last
Maine I know you're all wondering why
would he be reading a every magazine
well my wife gave it to me okay Dylan
himself is 74 years old and this is what
Dylan said and it's autobiographical
the greatest preacher and evangelist of
my time was Billy Graham that guy can
save souls and he did I went to two or
three of his rallies in the 50s and 60s
and this guy was like rock-and-roll
personified volatile explosive he had
the hair the tone the elocution when he
spoke he brought the storm down if I
could rename my book that's what I would
call it he brought the storm down clouds
parted Souls got saved sometimes thirty
or forty thousand of them well that's an
exaggeration but it's on the way if you
ever went to a Billy Graham rally back
then you were changed forever
there was never a preacher like him he
could fill football stadiums before
anybody he could feel the giant stadium
even more than the Giants could fill him
seems like a long time ago long before
Mick Jagger sang his first note or
before Bruce strapped on his first
guitar that's some part of the rock and
roll era that I retained I had to I saw
a Billy Graham in the flesh and I heard
him loud and clear
it's from Bob Dylan despite Graham's
Olympian status his long-term impact on
his times we might call it a legacy is
surprisingly elusive and hard
pin down the historian Stephen Miller
put it this way Grahams public persona
was always subtler and more oblique than
his strident platform rhetoric and vivid
media presence seemed to imply elsewhere
Miller captured the point with
brilliance of cygnus he said Billy
Graham may be America's most complicated
innocent align that the journalist David
Brooks applied to Dwight Eisenhower
recently applied equally well to Graham
Brooke said he looked simple and
straightforward but his simplicity was a
work of art think about that now for
clarity I will break Graham's impact on
The Times into four components the first
deals with religious ideas the second
with Evans a local culture the third
with American society and the fourth
with a politics of hope and at the end I
want to hazard a few comments about
successors for Graham so first of all
religious ideas and they do I check my
time here beginning then with ideas it's
important to notice that some of his
ideas remain fixed throughout his career
by my count there were seven religious
or some people would say doctrinal ideas
now we might call them evangelical
boilerplate but one of the reasons they
are evangelical boilerplate is because
Graham articulated them so often he gave
these ideas the appearance of always
having been here and the way he said it
and briefly I would say biblical
Authority the Trinity original and
universal sin a new birth through faith
in Christ the necessity of moral and
ethical growth after the new birth
mission something so wonderful has to be
shared and then finally the seventh a
final destiny of heaven or hell now
these were stable ideas that never
changed however
those seven claims though they remain
fixed at the core the way gram
interpreted and presented them did
change over time so I want to talk a
little bit about how Graham changed
those core ideas and then what that says
about how those ideas were received by
the millions who heard him first of all
over the span of his career Graham mood
from notions of biblical inerrancy and
literalism to a larger and more dynamic
sense of Biblical Authority simply put
the Bible was authoritative not because
it was accurate in every detail of
history and science but because it did
what it promised to do it infallibly
brought people to repentance and faith
in Christ in a variety of ways Graham
said that he trusted the Bible because
it worked in his own life and because it
worked in the lives of the people who
heard him from there Graham moved
backwards to say that the Bible events
substantial accuracy matters of history
and science but the key for him was not
inerrancy or literalism but
infallibility the ability of the Bible
to bring people to Christ that's one
change second change related to Graham's
understanding of the new birth in the
early days he effectively called for up
this moment conversion stand up walk to
the front sign a decision car join a
church and then go out and bear witness
as noted his trademark radio and
television programs had this bracing
title hour of decision his popular
magazine at the same title even more
bracing decision and the point was clear
choose Christ now right now but over
time Graham came to acknowledge that
Enquirer's registered their faith in
Christ in other ways he allowed that
many people including his wife Ruth
never experienced a moment of decision
rather they grew up committed Christians
and they never saw themselves
more to the point Graham came to see
that the majority of people in his
crusade hear me the majority of people
in his Crusades were not making a
first-time commitment but actually a
recommitment of those most have been
members of other churches but they had
drifted away and Graham called them to
come back to faith and shoulder the
responsibility of being a Christian
Graham's notion of moral and ethical
results that should follow the new birth
also changed over time this is a third
one now he always retained a primary
emphasis upon individual conversion that
point should be emphasized but it also
came to appreciate the need for an
intentional move from individual
conversion to working for social and
structural reform
he knew that move wouldn't take place
automatically converted hearts did not
automatically produce converted hands
this kind of social and structural
reform was never the center of his
message but over time he came to say
that it's important for Christians to
support civil rights laws and other
kinds of laws that brought about those
reforms Graham's notion of mission
broadened from a forthright verbal
proclamation of the gospel to a more
inclusive effort to bring as many people
as possible within the range of his
voice many people especially
fundamentalists charged Graham with
compromising clear example of that it
was the president of Bob Jones
University Bob Jones in 1966 said that
Billy Graham is doing more harm to the
cause of Jesus Christ than any other
living man
Graham was hurt but he never changed his
tactics his tactic always was bring as
many people within the range of your
voice as you possibly can
without sacrificing your core message he
did the same with mainline Protestants
work with them and they'll work with you
with Catholics with Pentecostals with
Mormons over and over he said if they
will work with me and do not ask me to
change my message I work with them now
today the idea of Evan Jellicle is
working with Catholics is it's no big
deal
but he started doing that in 1950 and it
was a big deal in 1950 and it provoked
the everlasting ire of fundamentalists
Graham simply wouldn't listen to the
critics
same thing with Pentecostalism seems
like not a big deal today to work with
any cause those are for Pentecostals to
work with other evan jolla calls but
when Graham started doing this in the
50s and 60s it was a big deal and it
took a major act of courage Graham
also called for an ironic approach to
world religions I think it's
controversial but I'm willing to stand
with it Graham never trimmed his
insistence that Christ was the only way
to heaven but he saw no point in
attacking other people's religions or
other people's traditions as countless
of angelica's did now a few times in
early years he violated his own
principles but as he matured certainly
from the 70s onward he went to great
effort to avoid criticizing anyone by
name and certainly not going into other
cultures and criticizing their faith he
said repeatedly my job is to preach the
gospel and not go to other cultures and
disparage them most controversially the
older Graham refused to speculate about
the ultimate fate of non-believers to
reporters who asked he invariably said
the same thing that's up to God
and I'm not going
to play God William Martin is the Dean
the Graham scholars and Bill Martin put
it this way
part of Graham's change came from his
wider exposure to a variety of peoples
and cultures if you've been everywhere
and if you know everybody and if you've
seen everything it's hard to believe
that there's only one way of angelical
culture we've been talking about his
impact on religious ideas has turned to
evangelical culture I turn now the
second broad area Graham's impact
evangelical culture I'm especially
intimidated talking about this with
Darryl's presence because he's written a
great deal about this topic but I'm
gonna be brave and go ahead the short of
it is this Graham became a badge of
credibility for Evans Allah calls he
brought Evan Jellico's out of the
cultural closet and he taught them how
to take a seat at the table of public
conversation in Graham's shadow
evangelicalism actually sometimes became
a style rather than a theological
position one of the finest historians of
American religion a man named Samuel is
he'll once put it this way
tongue-in-cheek
Billy taught evangelicals when to wear a
necktie along the way Billy also taught
the press that there were differences
among evangelicals and there certainly
were differences between em Angelico's
and fundamentalists for many years billy
defined the center of the evangelical
tradition george marsden historian many
of you are familiar with down the road
Calvin Marsden said it perfectly he said
he's quitting but he said an evangelical
can well be defined as anyone who likes
Billy Graham the preacher persuaded many
partisans including me and Christ did
not die on the cross to save sinners
from cigarettes or gambling or dancing
or playing cards rather Christ died to
save people from their sinful nature
and offer life everlasting both here and
in the life to come
grandma's know Richard Baxter he was no
John Bunyan but his preaching evoked a
sense of were the heart of the Christian
commitment should lie one more aspect of
his impact on evangelical culture
he taught of Angelica was the importance
of a practical approach to Christianity
we see this especially in the my answer
columns in the newspapers where people
would write in daily and ask every
imaginable question and these were what
prompted most of those millions of
letters they came in to the Graham
headquarters he didn't write the column
himself but he had proved it and it's
striking how concrete how practical the
answers were now most of them had a
heavy dose of boilerplate theology but
they also brought with him just common
sense
drawn from biblical precepts Graham's
mine these guidelines worked because
they have worked throughout history and
because they were in the Bible one of
his favorite lines you get in the
question and hands
excuse me in them my answer column is
eggs cannot be unscrambled very telling
letter woman who writes in she said I
had a sexual experience with a man not
my husband
long before we were married should I
tell him
Graham wrote back and he said that might
make you feel good but it will harm your
marriage confess your sin to God and
move on and then eggs cannot be
unscrambled Graham embodied decency this
is the last point I'll mention regarding
M Angelica culture again bill Martin
he said Graham represented Americans
best selves now it's almost needless to
say the Americans himself
and live up to their highest values but
Graham evinced an absolute commitment to
marital fidelity during even activities
that might raise eyebrows never dined
alone or the woman not his wife never
traveled a woman not his wife never had
the door closed with a woman not his
wife he was committed to financial
transparency again without compromises
they've done a public salary honesty
about numbers reflected another kind of
transparency tell the truth about the
numbers the people not if every crusade
was a success sometimes they were flops
and he said it comparatively few people
came but most tellingly reporters
constantly asked him how many converts
have you had to which he would always
have the same answer I have no idea only
God knows who a convert is so he called
them inquiries because you could count
inquiries but you wouldn't know whoever
convert was so that's the second area
first as religious ID is the second is
the changes he brought about Nevin to
agriculture third areas American
politics these considerations are not
going to bring me to say that he
affected American political life the way
a Lyndon Johnson or Ronald Reagan or
Martin Luther King did but he changed
Americans in subtler ways maybe more
profound ways ways that they bought
laying Fort Graham's brother-in-law and
a dear friend put it perfectly he said
Billy functioned as an arrow head on
most things the tip of the arrow pointed
in a progressive direction now that was
not across the board he was always
behind the curve on women's rights in
general and on women's ordination in
particular but to take a couple of
examples on the landmark issue of civil
rights Graham represented uneven but on
the whole steady prog
especially when you remember that he was
a white southerner growing up in the
1920s and 1930s as late as 1949 Graham
endorsed segregation that's the way
things ought to be in 1950 he began to
change he admonished his own Southern
Baptist Convention for their failure to
admit african-americans to their own
seminaries in 1953 he held a crusade in
Chattanooga Tennessee black people on
one side white people on the other a
rope down the middle as the municipal
law required somewhere in this
month-long crusade we don't know exactly
when he walked out and pulled the rope
down there was a lot of opposition he
insisted that the rope comes down Graham
is a human the next crusade it was in
Dallas and the ropes went back up he's
feeling along the edges coming to his
moral position and by 1954 the era Brown
versus Board of Education he determined
that those ropes would never again come
back up and he received ceaseless
vilification from white friends and a
fair number of death threats against
himself and his wife and his children to
be sure in the 1960s he began to back
off black power riots in the streets he
wasn't the only one who backed off and
called for temperance in the civil
rights movement but by the 70s he had
come back fully fledged in full support
of it in 1982 and the patriarchal
Cathedral in Moscow note the patriarchal
Cathedral in Moscow Graham said that
he'd undergone three conversions in
life the first was to Christ the second
was to racial justice and the third was
to nuclear disarmament through the
eighteen 1980s and 1990s Graham carried
disarmament as a torch with growing
bigger he preached as civilization was
on the brink of self-destruction and
that was not God's will
he called for discussion with the USSR
of the two nations differences and I
would say this move took enormous
courage because in those days which I
well remember evangelicals were not in
support of Graham's moved toward mutual
disarmament when the 1980s came the
culture wars came the Christian Right
he said he agreed with some of their
positions but he said people like Jerry
Falwell and Pat Robertson didn't talk
enough about poverty and hunger and he
said even if they did partisan politics
did not belong in the pulpit now you
have to say Graham helped pioneer the
cultural space that the Christian Right
eventually occupied and you also have to
say that some of Graham's
own actions in those years were slippery
if not duplicitous about his own
backdoor involvement in partisan
politics still in all he insisted
politics partisan politics does not
belong in the pulpit now I don't want to
suggest that Graham's impact was free
from flaws he made at least one grievous
mistake of a highly visible nature and
I've talked about this a bit but I want
to go back and focus a Morrow in 1972 he
made oh D s remarks about Jews
stranglehold as he called it
stranglehold on the media I was in a
private meeting with President Richard
Nixon an HR Haldeman in the
Oval Office those remarks came to light
in 2002 he was mortified and so were
Americans in general and Jews in
particular many Jews had considered
Graham their friend Graham apologized in
print repeatedly saying in a variety of
ways I don't know why I said it I did
not feel that way about Jews then and I
certainly don't know but that's no
excuse in the summer of 2002 a few
months after these conversations came to
light Graham held a crusade in
Cincinnati it's the home of Hebrew Union
University he met with a delegation of
rabbis he said to them the things I said
that day 30 years ago or unforgivable
but I beg you to forgive me one person
who was there that day remembers the
scene as follows he said the aging
Graham now in his 80s came into the room
and the rabbi stood grandma asked him to
sit down he said I'm the one who should
be on my knees unlike many Graham
supporters including his son Franklin
Graham himself did not try to spin his
mistake he faced it squarely he tried to
make amends by apologizing straight up
I've scanned a lot of newspaper
headlines and my sense of it is that
almost nobody forgave him and they
shouldn't have but most including most
Jews were willing to forgive them
finally I want to look at and have to
watch my time here I want to look at the
politics of hope
how Graham preached about the
possibility of a second chance in life
Misun transcended religious ideas a
transcended evangelical culture
transcended American politics for the
lack of a better term I'm going to call
it the politics of hope beyond
commitment sorry commitments to Christ
too it's Graham message that no matter
how badly you have messed up your life
Christ's willingness to forgive offered
a second chance the evidence lies in the
millions of letters that flowed into the
Minneapolis office only a tiny number of
them have survived but my wife was
helping me and we spent a couple of
weeks reading through those letters and
they are remarkable for their
testimonies of how people struggled with
addictions how they struggled with
loneliness most often older people whose
children never came around how they
struggled with sexual deviance and they
wrote to Graham and again and again
Graham said Christ offers a second
chance and I'd argue that the ideal of a
second chance goes back to the very
beginning of American history
the Puritans imagined themselves as a
city on a hill Thomas Paine
revolutionary firebrand said we have it
in ourselves to start the world over
again 19th century holiness will
proclaimed a second moment of grace the
Statue of Liberty with both of my
Ukrainian grandparents saw in 1902 as
they came by the Statue of Liberty
invited Europe's huddled masses to
breathe free and think of the names of
our political parties the Progressive
Party is a new deal the square deal the
new frontier compassionate conservatism
and yes we can all be token Grahams
instinctive sense that Americans were
prepared to hear his message of a second
chance and here too we hear echoes of
his impact on the ethos of the a
I want to say just a few words now I'll
keep this very brief will there be a
successor to Graham reporters call and
asked me this all the time and my answer
always is the same no and that takes
them back and I said are you sure as he
yep I'm sure
let's say this is especially dogmatic
coming from a historians because the
historians of all people had such a
terrible track record and predicting
anything I say no for a couple of
reasons one is that I think it's highly
unlikely extraordinarily unlikely that a
another person with voice and poise and
timing sincerity humility ambition for
himself and for God it just defines the
odds that another person would come
along
part of that achievement unique
achievement lies and the extraordinary
stamina that he possessed we don't often
think about that 60 years on the public
stage 60 years in which he knew that any
slip could be fatal to his ministry he
once told the Pope we have a great bond
because we are always on do you think of
what that meant he did succumb to the
allure of hobnobbing with people of
great power but there was never a hint
ever of deviance of personal propriety
there are other reasons why I think
Graham will not be reproduced but even
if this such a person were to come along
the America that created him and that he
helped create has passed we have to
think about how America has changed the
kind of new world that we have we no
longer have a small nuclear family
gathered around a flickering television
screen watching Ozzie and Harriet I
remember that in an age of social media
and Instagram would huge stadium
Crusades work anymore
the unprecedented devastation of World
War two the introduction nuclear weapons
the specter of expansionist communism
the fragmentation of American culture in
the face of racial and gender injustice
rise of seemingly unbridgeable culture
wars is just a few of the factors that
marked Graham's age and he provided
answers for that age some of them were
perennial answers about the human
condition but many of them addressed the
age that's hardly obvious to me that
another person like Graham could address
the age as he did so the question is
what will happen all right
write this down okay this is a grand
wanker on this day February 2 2016 here
it is I think we will see less heralded
or unheralded figures who might not even
know the name of Billy Graham they will
not be connected to centers of power it
will not be friends of billionaires and
presidents and kings as Graham was well
will they look like I'm drawing on wide
reading in American history historian
named Margaret bender authors
perceptibly sketched to what such people
will look like and I think she's
absolutely right
they will not be white they will
certainly not be white Americans they
will appeal to multi-ethnic audiences
they will affirm prosperity without
falling into the theological morass of
the prosperity gospel unhappily all will
be male yet like Graham they will esteem
chastity integrity sincerity ambition
humility and hope it will not be
doctrinally argumentative the doctrines
that evangelicals fight about today will
take second or third place behind an
insistence on a life-changing experience
with God and Christ
an experience that transforms every
other experience of life I conclude with
the reference to pilgrims progress John
Bunyan may have captured Graham's impact
with uncanny precision Bunyan said he
had in his pocket a map of all the ways
leading to or from the celestial city
wherefore he struck a light for he never
goes without his tinderbox one thing we
know for sure
however Graham's successors maybe
whether heralded or less heralded or
unheralded all of them will be living in
a world the Billy Graham helped create
dr. whacker has agreed to sign copies of
his book America's pastor Billy Graham
and the shaping of a nation immediately
following this session we now have time
for a few questions you want me to okay
yeah you briefly mentioned Franklin
Graham could you talk a little bit more
about the relationship between Billy
Graham and Franklin Graham and how you
see Franklin Graham's ministry today
especially with some of its more
divisive aspects relating to Billy
Graham's legacy you asked me if I would
talk about that no I I'm teasing
obviously that's a question that comes
up and reporters constantly asked me
they say who will be the successor and
then they say tell us about Franklin I
don't have inside information I did not
study Franklin on purpose so I probably
don't know a great deal more than anyone
in this room does I think Franklin is an
extraordinarily complicated figure he
founded and is the CEO of Samaritan's
Purse which the press seems almost never
to notice their paradin Spurs last year
gave away one no gave away more than a
half billion dollars in direct aid no
questions asked and some that egg goes
into Muslim countries digging Wells
building clinics so that's one side her
Frank on the other side of Franklin is
he's a culture warrior and his father
was not and I'm absolutely certain that
if mr. Graham were younger and could
respond to that question I am AB see
certain that his father would not
endorse Franklin's culture war positions
and he would agree with some of those
positions but his attitude would be in
irenic one and his attitude would be to
go back to what I said earlier bringing
as many people as you can
within the voice of the gospel just no
need to alienate people have a sense of
priorities he talked a lot about scale
some things are just more important than
others and what's most important is to
bring people to faith in Christ and a
lot of the things that Franklin's
worried about are things that Graham the
senior Graham just relegated to a lower
place damp yeah sir thank you very much
for your presentation so my question
first of all is what is your favorite
biography of Billy Graham and then if
you wouldn't mind discussing a little
bit of the scholarship behind that
favorite biography justifying why does
your favorite thank you okay good
question and I've been talking about
grandma a whole bunch since the book
came out and actually before that and
nobody's ever asked that question so
that's a unique question thank you
by far the best book on Billy Graham is
that written by William Martin Bill
Martin is retired now long retired but
he was a sociologist not a historian and
every time I see Bill I say why why
would you be sociologists I mean you
know I mean aren't you called to be a
historian but he was the sociologist who
wrote as a historian and he wrote a very
fat book that called profit with honor
and then it's the story of Billy Graham
came out in 1991 then a little bit after
that there was a children's edition
Zondervan children's version and Bill
has an updated version ready to go when
that sad day comes that Mr Graham leaves
us by far the best book it's extremely
detailed and it may give you a lot more
information about Graham than you want
but it's it's wonderfully written very
funny actually my own book is not in a
league with Bill Martin's but it's quite
different and that I try to look at
themes Graham as a preacher Graham as a
political figure Graham as a pastor
Graham in the context of American
politics so I follow it thematically and
the reason I did that it was because I
thought bill had already told the main
narrative story
and so I didn't want to reproduce what
he was doing but rather I wanted to be
able to slice the career in other ways
and look more closely at that career
yeah I mean for example one of the
things I look at a great deal is how
often the press commented on his looks
and I've looked at a lot of the
obituaries that will be coming as I say
when that sad day comes and almost
always the obituaries make a comment in
the first paragraph about how stunningly
handsome he was and then how that
facilitated the proclamation of his of
his gospel good it's a good question
yeah
okay
I would just ask you in terms of the
huge mega churches that have
proliferated and the superstars Joel
Osteen and his ilk no offense to anyone
who may be a huge fan whatever but what
what's your where do you see that in the
context of Billy Graham home wonderful
question you hear the question how would
I compare Billy Graham with the
prosperity preachers say like Joel
Osteen did I get that right Cheryl yeah
close enough oh okay it's a very fine
line between practical advice and
prosperity preaching and Graham's
ministry as I suggested is filled with
practical advice advice about how the
parents ought to treat their kids advice
to adolescents about how to get along
with your parents and that's the way it
came you know here's some advice on how
to get along with those older folks yeah
I mean you know so it's just very very
down-home some of it had to do with
managing your finances don't spend too
much don't overspend your credit cards I
mean is advice like that but Graham was
very clear to say that faith will help
you deal with your problems but it won't
make them go away and I think there's a
world of difference between saying
Christ will help you work through your
problems but he's not going to eliminate
Graham's ministry is not a deliverance
ministry I don't know of any instance in
his entire life when he for example laid
hands on a person for healing it's
possible that he did but it certainly
was not part of that public ministry
that Christ help you through life and
that was the essence of what I think he
had to offer yeah
so I'm struck by that Bob Dylan
quotation by the which quotation Bob
Dylan God Dylan yeah so Billy Graham
brought the storm down something to that
effect
yeah and videos that I've seen of the
Crusades in the 50s it does look like at
least if not Billy or mr. Graham sorry
cliff barrows that there's a pretty good
imitation of Elvis Presley but by the
70s I mean Billy is a brand and he's
more like IBM hmm so do you have any
sense that that Billy was aware of
losing an edge and maybe wanting to get
it back or was it part of reaching a
wider audience to become a brand
absolutely yes let me take that question
and in parts Graham was acutely aware of
the importance of cliff barrows and
George Beverly Shea and that's a whole
nother story in itself it's a book in
itself and our friend Edith Bloom opera
is writing a whole book on cliff barrows
and George Beverly Shea and their role
and Graham himself had no musical
ability Shea he said of Graham that he
has the malady of no melody he couldn't
hum a tune all right but he understood
the power of music in his Crusades and
so actually the very first associate he
hired was George Beverly Shea so he was
aware of their effectiveness and in the
begin actually Darryl in the beginning
they were billed as three and you look
at the early bills they say George
Beverly Shea Clift barrels and Billy
Graham and soon Graham moved out in
front Graham was aware that he had to
keep track with the times and he let his
hair grow long for example and it's
interesting that a lot of the letters
that came in bashed him for having too
long hair but he did his hair was you
know way down over his collar and in
other ways they brought in of why
variety of musical artists of rock and
roll of country music Gospels even music
that was distinctive of other ethnic
groups I mean he worked very hard to
bring a great variety of musical
traditions but when I say he worked very
hard that's a misnomer cliff did this
was cliff barrows genius to know that
you had to bring in a variety of musical
forms and that that would keep the
message current so in a sense it was
Graham doing that in that he authorized
and supported barrels for everything
that he did but barrels was the one that
had his antenna out very much I was at
the 95th birthday party and the only
thing and in cliff barrows was there he
is 85 at that time and the only thing
that Graham said at the party it was at
the end he asked for the microphone and
he said it was all possible because of
cliff and I think it's very
characteristic of him I mean he's
humility but also his sense of great
gratitude to what cliff barrels in and
Shea had done for him yeah great
question yeah you teach Duke so you've
probably heard of Methodists and Wesley
its skills at organizing people around
him for success so my question is going
to be to what extent Billy Graham and
this it's been half answered by that
last question but before you answer it
of the extent to which Billy relied on
his team and how he pulled his team
together I met you one I want to share
something with this audience I met you
on on Sunday and then yesterday I went
out and interviewed a gentleman that I
think you folks would like to know about
his name is Harold Mun he's a Hillsdale
College class of 47 his father was the
Dean here and and I said to him
please tell me about your first
encounter with Billy Graham and I wrote
this down he says my first early with
meeting with Billy was in Long House on
Waikiki Beach in Hawaii we had 20 or so
minutes
there and there was a little guy next to
me a missionary from Polynesia he could
hardly wait for a comment time and when
that time came Billy at the end of the
table was sitting next to me and the
missionary was on the other side of me
the missionary popped up out of his
chair and said Billy there are 20,000
islands in Polynesia where there is no
Christian witness and if you were to
spend one day on each Island it would
take you 60 years to reach them Billy
turned to me and said Harold we've got
to do something about that so here's
your Hillsdale College alumnus the
upshot was that we put in the most
powerful a.m. station and ever built in
Hawaii 50,000 watts with a signal
directed into Polynesia operating on a
frequency that fit between the channels
used in both Australia and Japan a Clear
Channel
because of that station during its
period of operation we heard from all
over the world because we literally had
worldwide coverage so Billy was
surrounded by technological geniuses on
the cutting edge of of media as well as
musicians and so on that you saw on the
stage so I wonder what you can tell us
about the behind the scenes operation of
the Billy Graham organization well I'd
like to go back to the question the
gentleman in the back asked about other
books on Graham one of the books that
desperately needs to be written is a
book about the organization of the
Graham organization Herald Myra has one
called leadership secrets of Billy
Graham but it doesn't get into the
organizational part very much and the
organization was a finely tuned machine
Graham himself was disorganized by all
accounts of the family he was
disorganized he was a fuss early and
nail-biter is all this but he knew what
his limitations were and he had an
astute ability to hire people who could
do what he could not and so early on he
hired George Wilson who was a superb
business manager in Minneapolis and he
turned it over to Wilson
having said that but I also see in my
research is that everybody knew that at
the end of the day Graham held the other
end of the
rope it wasn't just turn it over and
then let other people do whatever they
wanted to do
he called in every single day to ask
about the finances and the operation and
what was going on so it's it's a mixed
story it's a story of delegation but
with control and obviously it worked and
it worked magnificently there's one
other point I'd say there Dan and that
is Graham also had a clear sense that he
could do some things that no one else
could do he could stand in front of a
hundred thousand people and issue an
invitation and hundreds would come
forward he knew that he could do that in
a way that no one else could do so he
reserved that role for himself but he
delegated other things to this wonderful
organization he put together yeah
there's great questions yeah this
conference and previous ones we hear a
lot about gloom and doom that seem too
happy he sent a talk to America almost
50 years when you spoke last with Billy
Graham did you share a little bit in
this gluon to look to the moral decay as
many would call it I'm sorry my ear I I
just didn't get catechins you help me
Matt you were somebody well if you talk
about his conferences that's a that's an
interesting question
he was a dispensationalist
premillennialists but he never preached
it there are a lot of things that Graham
believed privately but he did not preach
about because he thought it was divisive
and so when he founded Christianity
today one of the founding planks of
Christian today was that they would
never touch dispensationalism because he
knew it divisive so there was a theology
that recognized the coming of
a collapse but my own view of this is
that it was wallpaper it was there I
don't think he took all that seriously
he was not an introspective man when he
looked inside I but he saw her sunny
skies
he wasn't introspective and one time he
said to Larry King I don't have many
cloudy days and I think that's very
interesting and he said that about
himself he was a man with a happy
disposition most of the time and and I
think that translated into the sermons
now the sermons always started with some
apocalyptic events that were coming but
very quickly those sermons moved into
the solution phase for these these dire
events thank you